[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois denis tillinac
pour son dictionnaire amoureux du
général je reçois diane ducret pour son
roman la dictatrice et jean-luc
fromental pour sa bande dessinée avec
berthe et de l'autre côté de la
frontière et l'on commence comme
d'habitude par cette époque que nous
sommes en train de vivre qu'est ce qui
la caractérise
voici vos réponses en images la vôtre
diane ducret s'affiche une image qui a
fait le tour du monde
c'est un je ne sais pas qui est le
photographe c'est une image d'entreprise
à venise lors de la dernière acqua alta
je trouve on dirait un géricault on
dirait presque une peinture
je trouve que c'est une est une
allégorie de notre époque de 7 ce
désastre écologique quand nous annoncer
qu'ils arrivent de consumérisme le
consumérisme guidant le peuple voilà de
ces asiatiques perdu dans un regard
comme ça de commence comment cela
peut-il s'effondrer on nous avait vendu
du rêve et ce rêve n'est pas au rendez
vous mais je me demande si elles ne sont
pas joyeuse en chef assure quand même d
acqua alta
ça date pas du réchauffement climatique
maintenant bien sûr mais bon c'est sur
la place saint marc ouais ouais je sais
pas j'ai l'impression que je trouve ça
rigolo
je ne sais pas moi je le vois une sorte
de détresse comme ça j'ai appelé samedi
à une quoi elle t'a dénis tillinac donc
les gens lui faut maintenant un nom plus
non plus dit moi je suis grand plus beau
plus que les autres alors votre photo
avoue jean-luc fromental c'est celle ci
alors s'agit dire ce que c'est alors une
photo que j'ai fait en bas de chez moi
dans la rue
le combo en question est un artiste
graphique de rue enfin street artist il
a fait un mur je crois dans le 10e
arrondissement qui reprend un peu ce
thème là et j'ai choisi ça parce que le
le blasphème contre les icônes c'était
toujours de suggérer dans le cas de
holmes et watson dans le cas de haddock
et tintin de suggérer une relation
homosexuelle entre eux voilà hélas pour
la première fois je trouve que c'est une
image qui est extrêmement dessus avait
et tranquille qui affirme quelque chose
et je crois que rien de choquant entre
ce garçon houppette et ce vieux loup de
mer qui s'embrassent et tout d'un coup
ça m'a fait comprendre qu'on était
rentré dans une autre époque où
finalement malgré les grincements les
les interdits les résistances bas voilà
on allait s'habituer à voir des gens des
hommes en train de s'embrasser
tendrement il ya quelque chose de très
doux là dedans que j'aime beaucoup voilà
je connais pas ce type là parfois des
tellines avec votre votre image à vous
très récente un cd hier oui je veux
c'est ce matin sur les écrans je trouve
que c'est une excellente symbolique de
l'inexistence politique de cette union
européenne soit disant 28 mai chacun
dans son coin mais là il faut voir
arriver des conférences ils sont chacun
ça c est ça traduit aussi les moeurs du
privé ont fait beaucoup de conférences
allez on y croit
les grands magnats et puis en même temps
c'est un peu anxiogène dams et 28 chefs
d'état qu'il laisse entendre qu'ils
peuvent quand même pas foutu de leur
risque minimum de se retrouver entre eux
est-ce que ça n'aille pas à cause du
corps réalisée bien sûr de nous aimer
exister qu'en avril
on doit protéger un peuple mais on ne
doit pas le on doit pas l'angoissé
ils sont en train de la folle et enfin
c'est surtout cette solitude quoi chacun
pour soi est d'ailleurs chacun chaque
pays concerné prend des souverainement
la slovaquie la slovaquie ce matin
l'italie heures les mesures les mesures
qu'ils croient devoir prendre
et puis c'est très bien comme ça mais
pourquoi pourquoi nous raconte
l'histoire de l'union européenne
ça fait plus rêver personne
c'est le spectre de james bond est donc
un chablon sur la beta vos blu feldman
science et ça c'est bien commençons
[Musique]
denis tillinac vous publiez dictionnaire
amoureux du général chez plon vous avez
écrit on va le voir sur la couverture du
général tout court
il ya même pas besoin de mettre son nom
c'est pas le grand homme d'état qui vous
intéresse c'est le héros vous pas ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la façon dont un chef
qui est chef de guerre chef tout court
sécrète un mythe et que ce mythe
héroïque puisse survivre à tout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment ils logent
comment il a éclos il a clos le 17 juin
quand un officier supérieur normalement
ambitieux entrant gouvernement par la
petite porte et est vrai décide de
devenir un aventurier de rompre avec
tout l'été se rétracter sous secrétaires
d'état la guerre du gouvernement paul
reynaud à la défense du gouvernement
tout d'un coup il devient un aventurier
mais il ya des aventuriers sont congelés
condottiere c'est le moi qui s'exalte
lui c'est un aventurier avec indécence
et la france alors une france idéalisée
il l'a défini dans les mémoires de
guerre comme
madone et princesses madone c'est la
pureté de la vierge princesse c'est la
noblesse donc ccsa france et à cette
france il va il va se vouer et le mythe
de devient héroïque de façon définitive
parce qu'il faut aller les circonstances
et le car arrive le tragique et le
tragique c'est là c'est la débandade du
gouvernement au long du mois de juin
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que ce que raynaud
fils les clés du 2e plus grand chose à
pétain et
il faut aussi gagner cinq rangs vin
qu'il faut que ce soit seul contre tous
le héros il est héros il l'affronté
comme dans les romans de latin mais
c'est de la table ronde 1 le chevalier
il affronte des épreuves
et puis les surmonter à la fin mais pour
moi c'est le 26 août 44
lorsque de gaulle descend les champs
elysées avec leclerc koenig ses
compagnons jornal maze pas les skis et
d'autres et qu'il entonne un magnificat
notre dame parce que soit voilà et la
république devient totalement légitime
il l'a fait adouber par les capétiens et
par les bonaparte
c'est un père parce qu'elle était très
contesté la république on peut dire que
tout le 19e siècle et un conflit de
légitimité dans ce pays depuis
l'exécution de louis xiii de louis saez
s'cusez moi et bien là c'est fini c'est
réglé et donc le mythe devient
indestructible il va résister à la je
vais résister aux échecs qu'il en a
connu beaucoup y avoir un parallèle avec
napoléon spa hasard si l'excellente
historiens gueniffey a publié un livre à
succès il ya deux trois ans que napoléon
de gaulle des airs français donc c'est
cette théorie héroïsme l'asl a même
survécu à la tambouille politique dans
laquelle justement au long des années 50
il a cru devoir se mêler n'est ce pas en
fondant le rpf
donc c'est un parti bart et antisystème
est parti un parti quand même et on ne
sait pas quand on est deux goals ben ali
est arrivé il n'y est pas arrivé je ne
vais pas arriver même soleil mais peut
être plus très lucide il était agressif
il était à côté de ses pompes quoi ils
étaient pas il n'était pas fait pour ça
c'est un chef tout court ce panneau
était plus un homme politique alors
votre dictionnaire commence par acdi
c'est accès de mélancolie dont
l'existence de du général de gaulle a
été jalonné la première épreuve dite
vous ce sont ces deux ans qu'ils passent
prisonnier en allemagne pendant la
première guerre mondiale
cinq tentatives d'évasion cinq échecs
dans ce terrible pour ses gratte la
guerre il dit
il va retrouver en 18 après la
après l'armistice des camarades de promo
qui auront été plus glorieux que lui
s'est battue vaillamment il s'est fait à
langer il a été prisonnier s'évade et il
dit le seul l'honneur d'un prisonnier
scène essayer le foute le camp ça n'a
pas marché
il donne des conférences il a bouclé
beaucoup et c'est beaucoup moins m'enfin
c'est année c'est un échec terrible il
disait je sais qu'il fallait plus pour
quoi il était sur terre trek à 15 ans il
avait écrit quand même une petite
saynète une pièce de théâtre ou un
certain général de gaulle à la tête de
l'armée française battez l'armée
allemande est sauvé la france le
deuxième l'échec du débarquement à dakar
en septembre 40 épisodes pour être
totalement oublié des lions sont
dramatiques passer des français qu'on
tirait contre d'autres français
des morts donc des français loyalistes
entre guillemets enfin en tout cas
obéissant au pouvoir de fait de vichy de
gaulle à débarquer pour commencer à
construire
l'armé de la seule la frange de l'armée
de la france libre à partir de dakar et
le le débarquement échoue
et on entend même dire l'amiral
d'argenlieu que le goal a pensé au
suicide
c'est d'ailleurs lieu qu'il a dit a pu y
penser on l'a dit plusieurs fois qu'il
ya passé aussi en en 1 43 en mai 43 sous
l'injonction de roosevelt churchill lui
coupe les vivres
c'est le troisième moment j'essaie de le
neutraliser alors là bas on dit qu'il ya
eu un moment de déprime puis il y avait
de quoi faire des échecs après il ya un
train chargé du désert janvier 1 46 sont
des flancs tizi hibel france il fait
d'être il reconstruit pays actuellement
provisoire avec des réformes
considérables et les allocs le droit de
vote aux femmes
les comités d'entreprise puis voulait
aller plus loin il était très marquée
par un catholicisme social sur le plan
économique social et j'allais dire très
à gauche serait beaucoup plus que son
entourage d'ailleurs ils y arrivent eux
pour savoir gouverner donc plus les
institutions de la troisième république
il échoue avant de convaincre les
français et fout le camp avec une
quatrième république qui ressemble à la
troisième personne république est très
loin de la cinquième de ses voeux ne
savait alors il revient à ses vingt ans
après dumas c'est formidable s'est de
fait le retour parce que tous les
français
beaucoup de gens les mégots lycée c'est
une confrérie retour d entre nous le
général et le le prolo lui espère que le
vol va mater les magnats les riches de
l'entrepreneur qui va calmer la cgt le
logiciel d'actifs qui va garder
l'algérie mais le
gars de chez moi les vues qu'un fils
militaire dans le contingent de forces
qu'il va mettre fin à cette guerre
devenue l'île nous renvoyer les gav est
vivant c'est possible personne ne veut
de gaulle pour la même raison mais on
veut d'eux en veut de gaulle de toute
façon et puis mairie curieusement et
revient mais à la fin 69 dernier échec
ysl ce rôle légitime et en avril 69 avec
un référendum qu'ils n'étaient pas
obligés de faire surtout n'était pas
obligé de mettre en jeu sa position de
chef de l'état pour lui ça va de soi et
il est d'avouer il doit s'en aller
d'ailleurs depuis mai 68 avait il ya
quelque chose qui s'est déconnecté
génération lui disent ils voudraient du
bonheur c'est au tour de gaule d'acier
de la vigerie un jour olivier le bonheur
en général le bonheur de la ch'ti mais
vous êtes fous le bonheur ça n'existe
pas ouais donc il avait plus rien à
faire avec une génération de disque
assez assez égaux ça aussi c'est le
propre du héros il a multiplié les
départs dans un pays comme le nôtre où
les politiques ne parlent jamais mais
faut bien voir que l'effondrement vs me
parler on retrouve toujours non et ben
oui par alors le 17 juin 40 vous l'avez
dit il au moment où il était au
gouvernement
ils sont là ont mené 46 en janvier 46
elle est libérée la france il s'en va
parce que la constitution qu'on vient de
voter ne plaisent pas parce que les
parties vont se retrouver au pouvoir
depuis le 20 mai jour du 27 avril 69
il s'en va et c'est quand même
extraordinaire ça c'est la vie dure
parce que ça vaut rien hier je souhaite
exercer mes fonctions cette décision
prend effet aujourd'hui à midi parce
qu'on n'entendra plus jamais la voix du
jura ce n'est pas un présent de la
république on voit que le diable au
salon du livre comme les nôtres depuis
j'irai depuis sarkozy ce jusqu'à est
revenu quasiment à tout de suite le
s'est fait élire conseiller
arbres resté un peu rare et solennelle
encore sous giscard mitterrand et chirac
c'est à partir de sarko pour des raisons
qui lui appartiennent
il a cru devoir désacraliser l'art in
sugen hollande on va pas et maquereau
qui a conscience je crois de la
nécessité de la restaurer dollar
sacraliser un petit peu bas on sent qu à
la fois l'air du temps puis les
maquereaux néant difficile n'empêche ils
essayent et elle a par moments c'est
avec l'accordéon commun c'était trop on
voit parfois jamais faire ce que
pointent un grand homme politique
adresse est doit jamais faire ce que les
communicants le 19 mai de gaulle il a
quand même toujours deux ou trois coups
d'avancé constamment stains ses
véritables ce qu'on appelle un
visionnaire produits vais d'ailleurs dès
le 18 juin 40
dès le 18 juin 40 et on le voit dans son
discours il comprend que on écoute tout
début de la guerre que l'amérique et la
russie vont rentrer dans la guerre est
pas de la façon on arrive en face à la
russie qu'on croit et je me suis
demandée je me suis toujours dit la end
que mitterrand a toujours voué à de
gaulle je demande si elle vient pas de
là mitterrand lui n'a pas eu n'a pas eu
la lucidité il a cru à la victoire de
l'allemagne mitterrand quand il sort
quand il c'est vrai il arrive à vichy il
croquait le terrain c'est un patriote
sincère qui est blanc comme de beaucoup
de sa génération que pensait que c'était
fini qu avec la france n'avait plus de
tout ça c'était vraiment ma patrie c'est
la france mon avenir et je pense à lui
je voulais à 2 go il n'a pas été plus
lucide que lui n'a bien sûr il n'a pas
vu arriver la réunification de
l'allemagne l'a pas vu arriver
l'implosion de l empire soviétique
c'est ce que de gaulle est le plus
visionnaire et vous avez raison alors
sur le plan militaire elle dit ça sera
une guerre mondiale ton tard les
américains seront obligés d'intervenir
la mécanique gains mais aussi le voilà
chef de guerre mais il dit la france
c'est moi le voilà chef tout court donc
il faut qu'il pense le monde pense le
monde d'après et des 41 effet une
conférence à oxford près des étudiants
français à oxford nakheel une analyse ce
que va être la société de consommation
de massifier
avec des imaginaires normalisées il ya
baudrillard et les six classes et de
bordes déjà dans ce discours en 41
l'officier né en belle époque c'est ses
produits jeu en revanche il n'a pas
compris la jeunesse quand mes 76 la
romance c'est vraiment ça va pas me l'a
compris la jeunesse de 1940 qui
n'aimerait compris la jeunesse de des
années 60 qui au bout de 10 en avait
marre de général c'est pas ça que pose
surtout devant j'avais 20 ans un pas que
je m'en fais le mieux il y avait
il y avait une problématique even ne
revendez parce que bon tout ce qui était
de l'ordre de la révolte contre les
autorités verticale l'armée la police
les curés les parents s'était un peu
fait dans les 50 ça me fait rigoler
quand on pense souvent que dany
cohn-bendit où l'on dit que ça a été une
espèce de l'effet recense de révolution
sexuelle soit en quelques dates des
boutonneux gauchos qui a aidé battant
dumont 70 visé j'aime aller les romans
de salon bonjour tristesse et 53 et dieu
créa la femme va dit mike bardot sublime
à poil c'est 54 56 l'autorité de nos
parents mais je vous assure beaucoup
décliné non tout ce qu'on attendait
c'était la pilule bon ça c'est le
meilleur bol du de la perle il l'accepté
limal de vol quand neuwirth misa santé
venus lui dire il faut plus qu'il faudra
rembourser
on va me rembourser la bagatelle il a dû
malbar dax allemand madame mais alors
parce qu'il a mieux compris parce
qu'elle a su qu'il y avait des filles et
failles et des cas de d'appartements
lamentable pour les jean paul est si
pauvre qui avaient pas les moyens
d'aller comme les bourgeois en
angleterre on va en suisse qu est la
friture aujourd'hui s'il ya quelque
chose d'héroïque chez le général de
gaulle est ce qui fait que aujourd'hui
alors qu'il a été vraiment détesté
hinglais toujours c'est cette fois que
je fais comme chroniqueur ici ou là tu
sais tu veux
j'évoque la figure la mémoire de gaulle
d'une façon ou d'une autre c'est
toujours plus tôt louangeux jeudi des
lettres d'insultés
c'est toujours les mêmes c'est tout ce
qu'il ya l'algérie et tout ce qui vit à
pékin
voilà enfin bon c'est quand même
minorité aubenas on a une famille
politique
alors maintenant 69 quand il s'en va
mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui dans son côté héroïque
c'est la fameuse phrase de françois
fillon qui imagine le général de gaulle
mise en examen
oui parce qu'en plus il se trompe c'est
à dire que le général de gaulle
aujourd'hui serait mis en examen comme
tout le monde
à l'époque c'est quand même tout à fait
un autre monde et médiapart n'existe pas
le canard enchaîné
mais ne fait pas dans kate devrait pas
de journaliste d'investigation il ya le
rtf lui appartient quand il vient ici
les réponses à l'avance pourrait lui
poser
personne ne lui parle jamais de l'argent
de la françafrique des polices
parallèles personnes non mais ça c'est à
dire qu'on est dans une démocratie qu'on
qualifierait aujourd'hui d'autoritaire
rubrésus démocrature alors ce qui est
vrai c'est que je pense à titre
personnel on pouvait pas il y avait rien
à dire vous pouvez investiguer autant
qu'on voulait sans doute d'une intégrité
bon nsany gens qui étaient autour de lui
il était pas moralement but valable que
ceux qui sont autour doté autour de
mitterrand à sarkozy de hollande ou ou
d'un maquereau héros de celui qui tire
les gens vers le haut d'un type
ordinaire vous faites vous fait un
compagnon de la libération que s'il n'ya
pas le aubin vos rivaux mais des grives
au potentiel il y en a autant que des os
que je vous dis ce que nous dira rivaux
et les magazines arrive dans une société
de jeux d'hier où les s de nos égos sont
tout ce qu'on nous promet la publ la
société de consommer ce que je veux dire
c'était plus facile à l'époque d'être
d'être le général de gaulle il l'avait
dit lui même le prestige ne va pas sans
mystère car l'on révère peu ce que l'on
connaîtra le prestige est encore à
portée de la main
on vous filme pas avec un iphone vous
n'êtes pas interviewer partira garçons
faut ou par yann barthès là parce que
j'ai un autre sa légitimité ne vient pas
des urnes elle vient de l'histoire vient
de l'histoire dans sa g n le midi le
mythe vient là de toute façon sous son
autorité était naturel j'ai encore connu
encore quelques-uns non quand il était
en face de vous le fais pas de plan
précis on n'a pas la chef d'état il
était en face d'un dédain fantômes qui
est porté par la mémoire longue de
l'histoire aspar et d'assistance alors
effectivement bons délais
et scandales il y en a eu mais si vous
voulez commis sa veste se tenir a tenu
il détestait auteurs les douves de la
ville c'est bien connu mais ils savaient
tous se tenir quand même davantage
et surtout il avait il avait décrit
délais dans le fil de l'épée ce que doit
être un chef la parole vous l'avez dit
doit être
il doit surprendre la parole doit être
rare et solennel mais ils savent plus se
tenir ils ceux des bombes
il passe par les politiques aujourd'hui
son lit sont les pentes pas alors c'est
un micro on ne peut pas on peut pas les
invités est entré encore quand c'est a
dit c'est pour dire des choses
intelligentes mais à plein temps c'est
pour dire des conneries il se démonétise
est ce qu'on doit faire autrement bien
sûr que oui les films et bien qu'elle
soit portable est bien plus que jamais
au moment des on est en une époque de
réseaux sociaux et de et d'info en
continu un pour échapper à cette espèce
d'europe de l'est ces mères qui fait que
ces décès des kleenex on les utilise
ils les voilà notabilisé on les utilise
et puis on les jette il devrait tout en
plus manière surtout les chefs 1 au
sommet disait cia roulera remarquerez
que et chaque président essaye quand il
est élu et à chaque fois on lui dit
qu'il est trop loin des français il
avait une bonne image au début macron
pendant l'e3 polémique ne fut que neil
que ne l'at il garder et puis dès qu'il
est sorti dans la rue on allons les
films et les téléphones portables au
moment où il disait qu'il voulait
trouver du travail elle est en phase de
le connaître la rue y en a et pas dix
autres et c'est trop exposés on a là on
va avoir encore une confiant la vue 3,3
fois depuis ce matin il le sait vu
madame ndiaye ad nous a dit qu'il y aura
une conférence du le président de la
république demain dire imaginer de
gaulle avec les coronavirus au fond et
un truc c'est sérieux quand même encore
voxan quand on convoque son premier
ministre et son ministre de la santé
alors dit bon vous allez vous occuper de
ça l'intrus qu il en parle même pas ce
n'était pas du niveau d'un chef d'état
oui mais parce que c'est pas le maire ya
eu un conseil de défense il va ailleurs
une quarantaine de morts parce qu'il ya
malheureusement des sur les dents comme
accidentés de la route tous les
week-ends irions-nous
délirant c'est des systèmes de nice
aujourd'hui le président de la
république est élu pour cinq ans comme
son assemblée nationale cctv alors
premier ministre il fallait vous avez
raison c'est une autre chose sans les
avantages du régime présidentiel
et puis il utilise pas le premier
ministre est fait pour être un fusible
il a un bon premier ministre edward fini
mais il n'est pas utilisé il n'est pas
utilisé macron et toujours il se met
trop en bon état est libre sommes de
toute façon le il valait pas adapté moi
j'ai voté de contrôler la pensée que
général de gaulle tiendrait aujourd'hui
ma chère pression qu'au bout de deux
jours il serait impopulaire et mis en
examen
cette race est biaisé parce que
j'éprouve une certaine proximité
étrangement alors que j'ai là 38 ans la
trentaine mais j'ai été élevé par mes
grands parents par mon grand-père
notamment qui avait été résistant qui
était né en 1924 et donc qui m'a qui m'a
élevée en parlant beaucoup du général de
gaulle et pour moi enfin le seul
président que j'ai connu dans mon
enfance et mon adolescence et le général
c'est très paradoxal donc au milieu des
années 90 est gaulliste est assez
étrange mais et puis mon nom mon parrain
était son chef de sécurité lorsque sa
place à l'étranger donc c'était quelque
chose d'assez présent je suis assez
proche de ce que dit denis ferrand et je
suis assez ému de l'aide d'écoutés j'ai
pas moufté depuis tout à l'heure
parce que parce que ça à la fois beau et
à la fois je ne sais pas cette épreuve
de la réalité mais le réel d'aujourd'hui
qui serait étanche à ce qui se passe qui
serait temps choses à faire encore
aujourd'hui mais je crois que justement
lui et est équipé pour cela d'abord
parce qu'un certain recul avec un
certain goût pour la métaphysique ca
certain sens de la solitude culture
générale une culture et une écriture et
surtout alors on lui churchill de
l'autre côté de la manche pour cent son
humour et son esprit mais le général de
gaulle n'a rien à lui envier
pour la france moi je trouve que la
meilleure parce qu'il résume sa phrase
qui résume le plus l'esprit française et
comment voulez vous gouverner un pays
avec 250 variétés qu'on a je trouve que
c'est tellement vrai et alors
aujourd'hui on a encore plus de vous
voyez que la france est définitive
décidé moi hein
tellement plaisir d'entendre quatre
carrés moi j c'est nettement plus jeune
que moi je dire ce que vous dites qu'on
peut dire denis tillinac sur mai 68 moi
je viens d'une famille mon père était
pilote de chasse de la première guerre
mondiale
ma mère était pieds noirs donc chez moi
de gaulle c'était le grand qu'on l'a
vraiment hockey ensuite de gaulle en 68
c'est quoi ses 1800 louette 18 ans et
une silhouette dessinée par signer donc
on fait tomber une silhouette en carton
on n'a pas vaincu le général de gaulle
on a vaincu cette société de nos parents
qui vivaient sous l'égide du péché de la
guerre mondiale parce que je pense que
tout le monde est sorti avec le poids de
la culpabilité de la guerre mondiale et
qui est donc il a suffi de faire et ça
me fait rien d'autre part les de tanis
parce que la photo de cohn bendit la
plus connue c'est ça il rigole avec un
intérêt sa faute car on voit là un peu
d'huile car auxerre est en phase donc
nous on a fait ça et pouf c'est tombé à
quai le sexe dans l'histoire
ce que vous décrivez c'est les gens plus
âgés que nous qu un permis baiser pour
dire les choses très clairement aux
nouvelles c'était pas ça c'est nous on a
porté ce qui était libre dans les
milieux huppés dans le peuple c'est à
dire et ça c'est la pilule c'est à dire
le droit a aux plaignants ont prédit
même et pour terminer on est dans une
époque où trump tweets et insultes
comment voulez vous que le général de
gaulle puissent exister dans une époque
comme ça général de gaulle avec ses
pouces sur le segment pousse sur un
petit clavier non c'est pas jouable
et pour finir moi je dirige un journal
qui s'appelait métal aventure le métal
hurlant et on avait fait une couverture
dans 80
3 et c'était une image de yves chaland
un dessinateur a présenté deux goals en
train d'égorger un soldat allemand avec
la photo et ça s'appelait de gaulle
seuls contre le reich et on vendait de
gaulle comme les aventuriers de l'arche
perdue et on avait fait un article
formidable sur de gaulle le héros et des
radeaux pour tenir la trajectoire voilà
mais oui c'est sans doute la dernière
figure historique
les figures héroïques de l'histoire de
france oui c'est la dernière
c'est la dernière en date oui c'est ça
je donne l'occasion
moi je crois que vous avez vous n'avez
pas tort devrait se comporter de façon
différente mais je crois que mes
messages restent vrais alors donc la
tenue le 60e porteurs de d'une mémoire
melon ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur
le 26 août 44 le l'inconscient politique
français c'est un trépied yahia
l'inconscient monarchie pas forcément le
régime a le regret de l'unité perdue ce
que macro à signaler dans une chronique
pendant la campagne présidentielle il ya
une triple républicaine très forte en
assurant elle remonte presque au premier
c'est le goût de l'égalité au premier
âge où les chrétiens
attendez la fin du monde et bart y
partager tout et puis à la grandeur
napoléonienne qui a généré tout le
romantisme français toute l'année je
suis venu trop tard dans un monde trop
vieux
on a mais on en est toujours là donc
c'est son message c'est qu'il faut c'est
dur d'être là d'avoir le cul ture attire
un trépied de me casser la gueule
il faut être à seaside deuxième message
ce qu'il avait dit un jour à palleschi
d'abord la france ensuite l'état après
le droit or maintenant il inverse tout
c'est pour ça qu'ils gouvernent mal et
n'est pas le genre pour pas content le
dictionnaire amoureux du général de
dit-il inac est paru chez plon ont fait
une pause on se retrouve juste après
mes invités sont aujourd'hui denis
tillinac pour son dictionnaire amoureux
du général jean-luc fromental pour sa
bande dessinée avec berthe et de l'autre
côté de la frontière et diane ducret
pour son roman la dictatrice diane
ducret qui a consacré déjà de livres aux
femmes de dictateur et qui sort
maintenant un roman intitulé la
dictatrice chez flammarion d'une
politique fiction où l'europe devient
une dictature avec une jeune femme à sa
tête c'est le succès de greta est une
dingue qui vous a inspiré
non je pense que c'est ça fait assez et
qu à ce que l'on a ce faisant on parlait
tout à l'heure finalement sur le manque
de gouvernance le manque d'exemplarité
le manque de charisme certains de nos
politiques
l'idée d'une europe qui a justement
grandi trop vite de manière trop
réglementée trop juridique en oubliant
peut-être certaines valeurs qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de droite comme
de gauche et pour des raisons absolument
différentes voire opposées demande sa
fin comme s'ils rêvent de construction
européenne aujourd'hui est un rêve de
désunion et d'un divorce consommé et sur
cette base là j'ai eu envie d'imaginer
de rassembler des morceaux de notre
actualité ce que je voyais et que je
trouvais très anxiogène alors si j'écris
livia deux ans il n'y avait pas encore
les gilet jaune mais j'imagine est
justement une europe où chaque week-end
toutes les capitales sont traversés par
des manifestations assez violente un
siège devant l'elysée un ministre saisir
de son véhicule disparaissant sous la
foule une épidémie faisant des millions
de morts des milliers de morts en europe
et une crise financière
là dessus avec un président russe qui
décident de déstabiliser le marché
économique mondiale je suis assez
farfelue ça commençait en 2023 manque
deux fois j'ai même pas eu le temps
d'arriver là que je suis rattrapé en
fait du coup ça il ya peu d'originalité
dans ce livre puisque tout est en train
de se dérouler donc cela dit je vous
conseille que l'europe est mûr
ouais je pense qu'on est mûr pour une
nouvelle un nouveau totalitarisme
pourquoi parce que justement par cette
ce manque de rassurance par ce manque
d'incarnation rajoutant avec ce soir
aussi d'avenir et d'espoir mais oui qui
acquit en at on laissé le champ des
futurs du possible de demain aux
religieux et aux radicaux aux populistes
qui nous vend
liant les deux mains lendemain
merveilleux ce champ là il existe plus
en politique si on ajoute à cela les
réseaux sociaux qui sont des armes de
contamination vraiment massive pour
certaines idées et la culture du buzz et
de l'instantané qui se fonde sur la peur
eh bien on va se chercher des messies
tout simplement pour allez incarner et
on est prêt à renoncer à notre liberté
individuelle et communes pour avoir la
possibilité d'être sauf à croire en une
idée à nouveau d'un de lendemains qui
soit qui soit autre que ce que l'on nous
vend entre les désastres écologiques et
financier qu'on nous vend et politiques
et migratoire n'en peux plus voir alors
d'habitude on voit la dictature plutôt
chez les nationalistes chez les
xénophobes à l'extrême droite
or vous c'est plutôt une dictature
féministe et que le gist universaliste
et pacifiste c'est pas du tout la
dictature avec elle on s'attendrait
contre laquelle on nous on ne cesse de
nous prévenir parce qu'aujourd'hui
attention les populistes et communisme
ou dont vous voyez c'est les gentils
vous pensez qu'ils ont passé les gentils
c'est léger les idées gentil qui vont
amener une dictature oui parce que
justement à l'art de donald trump
on a réduit notre vocabulaire à peu près
sans nom et donc notre catégorisation du
monde sont les gentils et les méchants
les nationalistes les internationalistes
donc je trouve que c'est extrêmement
réducteur et justement j'ai voulu un peu
triste et la donne et montrer quoi en
fait
ça commence en 2023 on a justement les
populistes qui sont arrivés au pouvoir
on a fait la fin de l'europe le livre
comment sur cette scène justement on est
à munich en 2023 les vingt-sept décide
du démantèlement d'europe puisque vous
savez quand un pays veut sortir comme
l'angleterre c'est une catastrophe
absolue juridique quand si tout le monde
est d'accord en fait les statuts
prévoient l'anéantissement en une
signature et donc on est ce jour là avec
cette femme aurore henry qui va jeter
une pierre sur un des visages de ces
féministes comme pour crier sa sa colère
et puis pour pour essayer de déchirer le
voile du réel de ce qu'est en train de
se passer
sauf que suite à ce démantèlement nous
n'avions pas prévu justement
l'indépendance énergétique
l'indépendance alimentaire et nous
n'avions pas prévu quoi les racines
culturelles les réaffirmer dans notre
éducation pour pouvoir supporter cela et
donc on a une situation catastrophique
avec donc une épidémie
un krach comme en 1929 on est 100 ans
après et là ce que je voulais montrer
c'est que justement lorsque l'on est mûr
qu'il y ait un vide de conscience un
vide de formation et de soutien
intellectuel
même les idées a priori les meilleurs
peuvent donner du totalitarisme elles
sont pas forcément celles que l'on croit
aurore henry à la base un programme très
féministe elle veut remettre en avant le
féminin sacré le lien à la nature un
programme écologique
un programme très harmonieux mais dès
lors que l'égalité entre les hommes et
l'harmonie vous l'a décrété vous
l'imposé là on commence à voir quelque
chose d' aliénant elle a un discours qui
est fondée sur celui un peu des
politiques d'aujourd'hui qu'on voit un
peu inspiré de d'école de commerce avec
le bien-être pour tous le bonheur et
c'est de la caricature et parce qu'elle
est plus sincère que celle plus
intensive fin c'est pour ça que c'est
pas anglais la merkel non c'est pas
marine le pen s'est pas marion maréchal
non elle est sans doute au greta kinberg
pas dans le sens mais parce qu'elle a
une espèce de l aile de elle vient
naturellement comme moi sur le devant de
la scène est lié elle y est à son aise
et voilà je la veux je te trouve plus
proche des citoyennes en fait engagé
c'est une vraie citoyenne européenne qui
aime et qui voit quelque chose qu'elle
est sanctionné de marketing que vous
songez que les mots et les idées telles
qu'elles vont s'incarner sont ces choses
là
non elle est là une sincérité absolue
absolue tout comme d'autres sont en
avant elle c'est justement voulu en
faire une réplique des d'hitler avec
s'entendre décalage au féminin
d'ailleurs elle a les mêmes initiales
que hitler elle s'appelle l'aurore henry
pourquoi je trouvais intéressant d'abord
de me poser la question est ce que cent
ans après on serait mûr entre guillemets
pour ça on me répond toujours deux
choses - yahia dans les discours
ambiants de phrases qui m'inquiète c'est
toujours où il fait on est quand même
beaucoup plus informés qu'en allemagne
en 1930 et aujourd'hui enfin jamais des
discours comme ça ne passerait permettez
moi d'en douter
et ensuite c'est oui mais une femme oui
la femme est l'égal de l'homme bien sûr
mais bon elle est plus douce elle et
maternante jamais une phrase une femme
ne serait dictateur alors ça m'agace et
je trouve que c'est dangereux dit est ce
que c'est vrai dans l'histoire il ya eu
des femmes catherine de russie et
l'impératrice city il ya eu 10 ans king
la dernière épouse de marc hautbois et
la chienne de mao qui a été jugée et
emprisonnée
il ya eu des femmes absolument demander
là des femmes à poigne alors tout cas
pas pouvoir oui du monde mais là elle
était elle son esprit dans le principe
oui mais il n'y a jamais eu de femme en
tout cas qui a conquis par les urnes par
les idées et qui surtout a donné
naissance à une idéologie totalitaire
donc moi j'ai envie d'abord tout
simplement de me dire est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on pourrait avoir
justement a réponse à tout ce qu'ils
disent mais enfin aujourd'hui on est
mieux on est plus informés se dire voilà
vous voyons qu'en imaginant la
progression très lente sur 15 ans d'une
idéologie totalitaire et au départ c'est
formidable et puis ç'a marché
et le pire c'est que ceux qui lisent le
livre au début les premiers retours ses
bras son programme quand même enfin
quelqu'un qui a compris ce qui se passe
en europe enfin quelq'un j'aimerais bien
voter pour elle le souci c'est que j'ai
transposé des discours entier d'adolphe
hitler auquel j'ai changé quelques mots
est une chose l'obsession pour les juifs
remplaçant ça d'une obsession écologique
ou féministes et alors là on applaudit à
deux mains et puis mettre les musulmans
se marchait bien aussi c'est pas
forcément ce qui m'intéresse le plus je
trouvais il ya déjà le choc des
civilisations de huntington qui est très
intéressant là dessus il n'y avait pas
besoin de ça dans un roman en plus je
crois
puis c'est déjà traité par welbeck aussi
notamment dans soumission mais en tout
cas
mais le fait que vous ayez voulu en
faire une réplique avec le décalage ça
commence en 2023 parce qu'en 1923 le
plus sobre
c'est le putsch de munich hitler se
retrouve en prison ou lemberg tout comme
elle se trouve en prison la même
hollande berg et c'est là qu'il devient
finalement populaire connu célèbre et
qu'il écrit mein kampf et elle s'est un
peu les choses et mémoire voile alors
qu'en plus elle a été filmée pendant ce
geste est vraiment son procès donc le
temps qu'elles sortent de prison
elle a fait des millions de vues d
millions de kills elle est devenue la
voix de la rébellion et de cette époque
qui va créer des icônes et des idoles en
un clic en un instant mais en même temps
je vous apprendrai pas et vous le savez
mieux que moi que l'histoire ne se
répète jamais et que de vous être
enfermé vous même tout seul dans un
créneau en crescendo qui a existé il ya
un siècle mais qui de toute façon vous
savez bien ne pourrait pas se répéter à
l'identique
pourquoi vous êtes infliger ça si vous
lisez bien il n'a absolument pas annoncé
comme ceux ci diffèrent mais on est
quelque chose d'absolument différents
justement elle elle veut reconstruire
l'europe elle veut réaffirmer quoi les
racines grecques elle veut réaffirmer le
lien à la terre première elle veut se
séparer justement de la russie elle veut
se séparer du pétrole arabe du gaz russe
de l'influencé recréer une sorte d'
europe qui serait l'équivalent
paradoxalement de la grande russie à
l'époque communiste mais chez nous avec
un discours totalement inclusif etc
on est au contraire je trouve en en
négatif de ce qui s'est passé
ce que j'ai voulu recréer en revanche
c'est la scansion de l'arrivée au
pouvoir d'un totalitarisme et c'est
cette métaphore de la grenouille qui est
d'ailleurs d'un livre savais que je
prenais une grenouille vous la plonger
dans de l'eau bouillante et bien elle va
bondir et ça et ce bar est tout de suite
si vous la mettez dans une casserole
d'eau froide et vous mettez un feu très
doux
elle va se trouver à son aise relaxé
absolument et une fois que l'aube où
elle meurt parce qu'elle n'a pas senti
elle ne s'est pas rebellé
je crois que c'est assez proche de ce
qui peut se passer aujourd'hui et en
cela si ça peut complètement d'un mois
je me disais pourquoi prendre toujours
hitler comme archétype est depuis
comprends hitler comme archétype du mal
de la dictature du totalitarisme
je me suis ça nous aide bien à
comprendre le totalitarisme a dit hatton
il me semble que si on n'a pas compris
staline et si on n'a pas compris mouse
et en particulier parce qu'on avait
cette idée que le totalitarisme la
dictature le mal c'est est hitler et
uniquement si hitler et que je me
demande si ça nous prépare à vue à
comprendre trump qui n'est pas la
voiture parce que d'abord dans le lit
vite l'air n'existe pas la seconde
guerre mondiale n'a jamais existé donc
on dessine une toile vierge et les
éléments que j'ai caché qui sont ensuite
les rien sont absolument indétectable
pour certains lecteurs
les lecteurs jeunes qui eux et c'est ça
qui est intéressant à eux n'ont aucune
idée de quoi je parle et pour eux je
vous assure c'est pas une répétition il
trouve ça juste à moi c'est fou que cela
puisse se passer d'exagérer pas hitler
que baho et staline parce qu'on leur
rebat les oreilles
sauf que comme là il n'est jamais cité
balle et j'ai le cas avec des étudiants
de première année de sciences po qui
l'ont pris pour des devoirs et qui en
effet ne détecte et pas qu'il était
parti qu'à l'époque elle allait à la
même prison qu'elle était condamnée dans
le même juge donc ce sont des choix
extrêmes et là on les voit pas mais
ensuite c'est vrai qu'on a au regard on
a évidemment un autre personnage qui est
celui de la mère qui est en en creux qui
elle est d'origine russe et donc on a la
chute en fait
or henri elle n'est donc en 1989
s'entend après hitler mais elle n'est
surtout l'année où finalement le bloc
soviétique commence à se fissurer à
tomber et on a le personnage de la mère
qui elle incarne cet idéal russe donc on
a finalement sorte de staline et hitler
qui se regardent l'un l'autre avec deux
destins assez différent non je trouve
qu'au contraire c'est une gageur et que
c'est justement assez intéressant de
montrer la manière dont aujourd'hui
peuvent surpasser les choses voyez il
clair une couverture du time magazine
personnalité de l'année greta tune berg
aussi donald trump aussi c'est à dire
finalement vous dites que je répète mais
s'ils sont les médias qui répète c'est
l'histoire qui se répète et or henri si
elle existe et demain serait évidemment
personnalité de l'année pour ses combats
et est ce que vous pensez qu'une guerre
mondiale est encore possible hitler
c'est à la fois le produit de la
première guerre mondiale et il va
disparaître avec la deuxième qu'il a
provoqué largement aujourd'hui une
guerre mondiale où il y aurait l'europe
face à l'amérique et la russie alliée
contre elle ça durait plus cinq ans elle
durera
en revanche c'est une fable évidemment
même si c'est romanesque et c'est très
politique à mon sens c'est justement une
fable un miroir un petit peu déformant
de notre actualitté mais un miroir quand
même qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce
livre il ya évidemment les états unis a
l'air de trail en tout cas dans une
réélection puisque dans le livre trump
est réélu finalement là aussi c'était
écrit à deux ans nous dirigent
visiblement vers ce scénario avec la
tribu routine est toujours là divers
tous il est toujours là il s'appelle le
maître de l'est et en revanche il se
passe quelque chose d'intéressant c'est
que lui voit justement dans cette danse
est destruction finalement de l'europe
dans cette désagrégation il voit son
intérêt pourquoi de recréer d'abord une
grande russie très fortes et aussi une
sorte de de retour sur le traitement
assez particulier cette mise au ban de
la diplomatie européenne qui le subit je
pense dont il est assez mécontents et
qui en fait a tout à gagner tout à jouer
du point de vue énergétique notamment en
coupant les projets de nord stream et
nord stream 2 c'est-à-dire en supprimant
le gaz russe qui aujourd'hui quand même
30 % grâce à gazprom mais pas que mais
qui a une projection justement qui est
celle du livre à 2029 et à plus de 50 60
% de l'énergie européenne
on efface donc à quelque chose c'est
intéressant de voir qui on ostracisé
aujourd'hui peut mordre demain la
dictatrice c'est un roman de diane
ducret ça vienne paraître chez
flammarion
[Musique]
jean-luc fromental vous vous publiez de
l'autre côté de la frontière
avec philippe berthet chez dargaud est
une bande dessinée qui se passe en 1948
pourquoi cette prédilection chez vous
pas seulement chez vous d'autres auteurs
de bandes dessinées de votre génération
comme floch ou l'oustal avec qui vous
avez travaillé d'ailleurs le dessinateur
célèbre cette prédilection pour l'après
guerre
j'ai l'impression que ça vous ça vous
fait tous rêver esthétiquement mais pas
seulement esthétiquement nombre d'albums
de bandes dessinées que vous avez
scénarisé se passait toujours juste
après la guerre la nostalgie de ce qu'on
a à peine frôlé de ce qu'on a failli
connaître je pense c'est des années en
1956 l'inca aux sons et des
petits-enfants décès sont des enfants il
est un peu plus jeune que moi il a eu
deux heures à cinq ans ou six ans de
différence on est des enfants au sein ce
moment là donc le monde n'existe pas
pour nous c'est notre maman notre papa
et éventuellement quelques albums de
donald duck
mais en tout cas pas du tout ce monde là
et moi il ya une raison particulière
spécialement pour cet album c'est j'ai
commencé à travailler dans une une
espèce de la bande dessinée se cherche
des sujets en ce moment parce que elle
elle produit une façon excessive
d'ailleurs mon avis on sur 5600
nouveautés par an cette venue mais
ronald diablement élargit le spectre
matin sous les romans graphiques et les
héros les séries d' aventure comme avant
et puis les romans sur le réel les
enquêtes les reportages absolument nous
raconte le monde d'aujourd'hui
comme je dis peuls des risées la
littérature est on en train de prendre
parce qu'on est dans ciels de l'image et
que l'image répond à l'image l'image
parle à l'image les voix individuelles
s'exprime à travers l'image pour
répondre au go caméras de
télésurveillance ou quelque chose comme
ça moi j'ai une collection de petites
collections de d'en dessiner chez denoël
qui s'appelle donald graphique où je
publie vraiment des bouquins qui vont à
la frontière oubli posy simmonds
je publie altarriba qui a fait un truc
sur la guerre d'espagne magnifique l'art
de voler je publie des gens qui qui qui
vont chercher les lecteurs de romans
aujourd'hui qui sont tout à fait
disposés adultes a maintenant lire des
machins avec des images ce cas pas
toujours été le cas un tel vent qui les
ait fait paître les ferries matin il
regarde des séries à saint mais il ya
aussi le fait qu'on est rentré en une
génération d'adolescents comme on disait
c'est à dire que on accepte qui est des
petits mickeys ds qu'on raconte et du
coup la qualité monte parce que les gens
qui s'approche de ça j'ai publié un
bouquin sur théodore herzl de camille de
toledo qui a été un écrivain hypra ses
aïeux de chez gallimard etc qui est un
roman graphique sur théodore herzl qui
est une merveille fanjeaux dont je suis
extrêmement fier et publié aussi bien
israël qu'en turquie et en egypte par
exemple ce qui est un exploit
donc voilà et donc moi je travaille
plutôt vers la bombe destinée centrale
c'est-à-dire vers le mainstream je dirai
pas ce que je crains que ce mainstream
de ces fonds puisque les éditeurs
s'intéressent de plus en plus ce roman
graphique et à cette espèce de
littérature dessinée et le problème
c'est je vois arriver là ce qui est
arrivé à la littérature française à dire
qu'on est en train de partir dans une
espèce de surenchère des sujets ou pour
devenir un auteur visible il faut avoir
mangé sa mère elle a été plusieurs fois
violé par son papa
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai problème
donc moi je reviens vers des auteurs qui
sont plutôt identifiés comme des auteurs
mainstream berthet ça fait 30 ans qu'il
est à la manoeuvre qui fait des livres
comme ça et j'ai développé depuis un
album que j'avais fait avec un ami qui
s'appelle josé louis bocquet un
dessinateur qui s'appelle stanislas qui
étaient les aventures d'hergé qui était
un biopic d'hergé mais racontée avec de
la fiction de dans un une idée de postes
biopic
c'est à dire que parce que vous des
marie curie aujourd'hui vous en avez 50
ans bande dessinée c'est plus très
intéressant et donc je travaille avec
mes vaches sacrées j'ai fait il ya deux
ans un livre
graham greene tout d'un coup était perçu
comme un espion et ça se passait pas
grand coster 2
britanniques notamment de roman
d'espionnage mais d'autres voient là le
facteur humain qui est un roman
splendide et un très beau film de taper
d'otto preminger voilà et moi je
m'intéressais aux tournages de deux du
troisième homme qui couvrait dans mon
récit une mission de graham greene à
vienne pour retrouver ce soir je vais
d'abord me revient toujours à cette
fascination pour les années 50 et quand
vous démarrez dans les années 80 c'est
très à la mode on est dans le rétro est
donc dans les années 80 on est
nostalgique des années 50 c'est
aujourd'hui est ce que ça vous semble
pas lointain 7 après guerre si vous
décrivez si ces voitures et les trois
mousquetaires sa passion du mal à
capellia derrière absolument enfin
toutes proportions gardées mais j'ai
l'impression de travailler avec un
matériel qui pour les gens d'aujourd'hui
n'a plus est par exemple de galez
puisque ça se passe à nogales donc une
ville très particulière sur la frontière
américano mexicaine et qu'une partie aux
etats unis une partie au mexique une
ville qu'on voit dans la soif du mal
très beau film d'orson welles ça se
passe là et qui à l'époque ne sais pas
si longtemps encore le câble je sais pas
d'ailleurs si nogales on ne parle plus
de degrés c'est totalement dans
l'actualité
ah oui mais en hausse de donald et de
son mur ah oui toujours pour ça parce
que la nôtre canalsat harry est un
exemple nogales est un exemple
absolument extraordinaire d'à la fois la
permanence et la porosité des frontières
c'est à dire que nogales il se trouve
que a lâché de transactions des états
unis avec le mexique
c'est une vie qui se trouvait un coup
vraiment à cheval et jusqu'en 1914 pour
passer des etats-unis au mexique on
traverse la ruche il n'y a pas de mur il
n'y a pas de grillage et pas de
barrières rien du tout tout va bien
c'est les mêmes gens qui vivent de
l'autre côté de la frontière c'est les
mêmes
personnage qu'on vécu les guerres
indiennes qu'ont vécu les conquistadors
qu'ils sont les descendants des
conquistadors des pionniers en groupes
espagnols américains tout ça se mélange
allègrement et il n'y a pas de problème
et puis il ya un mec qui s'appelle
pancho villa qui commence à venir un peu
trop souvent du côté américain
je commence à se comporter un peu mal du
côté américain et là on décide que bon
il n'y avait quasiment il a il a occupé
la partie américaine dit logan est la
partie américaine donc on dit bon match
en cage chez soi on va commencer
mais c'est le début de ce qui va
aujourd'hui être le média pas contre un
livre d'aujourd'hui tout à fait mais
mais dans le sens de nos gars laisse à
l'époque où vous situez votre action
c'était vraiment une espèce de bordel
quasi coloniale pour les américains
alors ça c'est l'idée luc table pour
résister de la frontière c'est quand que
vous avez d'un côté des gens qui
cherchent du sexe et de l'autre côté les
gens qui cherchent du pognon pour manger
et que les très jolies filles ben il se
passe que les uns vont d'un côté et les
autres vont de l'autre et les uns
apportent leur argent du côté mexicain
pour acheter du stupre et les autres
viennent servir les wasps dans le
secteur rapports de domination n'y a pas
de yap adam érotisme particulier chez
mexicain qui attirait les amériques
c'est sympa une licence il ya une chose
il ya d'abord il ya des utilisations de
repreneur il ya utilisation protestante
d'un côté et catholiques de l'autre et
c'est la base même de l' échange celles
d'un côté le sexe et on ferme les yeux
c'est sympa et on fait une prière on est
on est volé par des métadonnées on va à
confesse c'est terminé et donc
et puis il ya la nécessité et il ya le
fait que ces femmes se vendent pas par
plaisir
pas par nature sexuelle et
particulièrement en ébullition mais
parce que c'est aussi le seul moyen de
ces rencontres et du fric et c'est donc
et ça parle ça d'une image qui nous une
image qui me vante depuis que j'ai lu
tout ce que je pouvais lire sur lui
parce que stan mais les auteurs fétiches
qui est georges simenon et jean chine on
a passé étant parti de france en 1945
après avoir un peu beaucoup travaillé
avec la continental ce qui nous ramène
société de production d'asi de cette
production nazis il n'a rien fait de mal
rien fait de mal mais il a vendu autant
lara fait quelques films etc
donc ça sent l'udemo vers du nez
scénario qui ont été par ailleurs s'il
n'en a pas encore de carrière américaine
à ce moment là il veut absolument sonné
la stature aux états unis qui l'a en
europe n'a les amarres est dans
l'arizona et il part tout maccarone
entre les piqûres et ensuite chaleur et
chaque femme par dont il fait son tour
il fait son tour de dudu des états unis
et en 48 il arrive dans la santa cruz
valait qu'on appelle à ce moment là
également la sente à bousval et booster
la gnôle en anglais parce que là vivent
les gens de la côte ouest les
hollywoodien du type janoueix une soit
granger qui picole sec et puis qui se la
raconte pas au niveau de la gaudriole
viennent planter le alors leur amour un
peu
compliqué et les gens de l'est les
cadres de la general motors etc viennent
aussi pour fréquenter des acteurs et
pour se lâcher
il s'adonnera le fond de la bouteille ça
donne cette admirable oriana deuxième
d'ailleurs bien intégrés et le corner
mais grêce corner mais aussi wii puis on
a d'autres il ya là j'ai eu mon père
dualisme à pékin où elle s'était
qualifiée un peu votre héros donc est
inspiré de georges simenon donc qui
vivaient là en 1948 et qui vivait là
avec sa femme avec son fils aîné mark
avec sa maîtresse qui était sa secrète
de visu oui mais voilà qu'est devenue sa
deuxième femme et de layrac sa
gouvernance et les grandes villes et
dans notre beau et surtout cela et ils
sont tous là je n'appelle pas georges
simenon alors il s'appelle françois
content parce que j'en chie ils n'ont
qu'a raconté sa rencontre avec denise
oui mais à new york avec trois camarades
à un chef-d'oeuvre
et dans ce livre il s'appelle lui-même
françois combien beau film aussi qui a
été tiré de sa et de nissan est en
moyenne et il ne vais pas arriver ce qui
était inscrit votre héros qui se
retrouvent à enquêter sur une série de
meurtres de prostituées c'est là dans
les galeries ses voisins et est
appliquée on soupçonne et il se met à
enquêter c'est là qu'on est dans le
poste bio clic c'est à dire que là avec
une précision j'espère de chirurgiens
jeu greffe sur mes vaches sacrées qu'ils
m'apportent quelque chose de magnifique
qui sont des personnages hors du commun
et sur lequel on peut se caler parce
qu'ils ont tellement écrit sur eux-mêmes
tellement autobiographie et leur vie d'à
travers leurs romans que on a tout le
matériel psychologique de ces gens là je
greffe quelque chose qui est d'un autre
complètement différent ailleurs votre
héros je parle pas de simenon mais je
t'ai que simenon faisait la même chose
votre héros quand il va à nogales dans
les bordels photographier des filles
avec sa secrétaire maîtresse qu'est ce
qu'ils cherchaient c'est un libertin un
voyeur un départ assez vanter d'avoir eu
dix mille femmes au delà c'est votre
héros c'est sa secrétaire blonde et une
brune est célèbre à fellini il se
vendait le rue d'isle femme dans sa vie
et
il précise immédiatement je n'étais pas
un vicieux je ne cherchais pas le vice
dans le sexe simplement je cherchais la
femelle est de la même manière qu'ils
allaient 10 sur les dix mille aidé
beaucoup de prostituées et 8 min aussi
tué de la même manière qu'ils appliquent
aux humains qu'ils observent cette
espèce de recherche permanente de l'eau
menus je pense que sinon est une espèce
de 2,2 de minotaure de 200 torque a
besoin sans arrêt sans arrêt mais c'est
comme chirac ces cinq minutes douche
comprise est pas du tout romantique
verrait bien que vous voyez georges
simenon aussi que j'ai consacré un livre
c'est aussi le une de mes passions
littéraires avec proust et balzac et
châteaubriant je suis assez d'accord
avec
avec ce que vous dites c'est mais le
départ aux états unis surtout parce
qu'il avait l'imaginaire français était
épuisé les ressources et sont intervenus
après enfin 56 ya une question il ya une
question que je me suis posée puisque là
il se retrouve à enquêter genre sinon le
m 2 du roman policier c'est comme ça
qu'on le conte le qu'on le voyait à
l'époque je crois pas que ce soit jamais
arrivée qu'à un auteur de romans
policiers se retrouvent à véritablement
enquêter sur un crime sicile agatha
christie conan doyle attaque russie a
oui comme un conte en deux sets très
connue bien il ya un livre de comme ils
s'appellent julian barnes là-dessus où
il mène une enquête sur des meurtres
d'animer sa servante et partout viennent
pas du tout ah non c'est vraiment vrai
histoire oui et et pour défendre un
indien une snes de petits noté indien
qui est accusé de la question c'est ça
est ce qu'un bon auteur de romans
policiers se révèlerait un bon détective
dans la vie en tout cas il il en rêve
tout ça il en rêve tous ils aimeraient
ils aimeraient même un type comme de
lynx plus près de nous et quelqu'un qui
un moment faisait beaucoup des listes le
jour où je vois ce n'était pas des
enquêtes c'est énorme et c'est déjà un
côté détective quand même
et je pense que quand on a la passion de
ces mécaniques la chevillé au corps
comme comme ils l'ont tous
je pense faire que le mécanisme
policiers intéresse particulièrement si
le nom en dehors de ça je dirais que
c'était un alibi une manière de faire
c'est sinon c'est un mec génial qui vend
ses brouillons sinon il a écrit quoi 300
romans sur les 300 il y en a 200 qui
sont les brouillons de ses
chefs-d'oeuvre
il vend quatre fois l'histoire de
l'escalier en faire jusqu'à arriver à ça
c'est un type c'est un modèle économique
en soi sinon extraordinaire derniers
modèles de créer sur georges simenon que
je connais pas que je connais pas c'est
bien finalement qui me manque qui me
manque pour l'instant mais agatha
christie pas mal quand même pour ramener
un peu de femmes dans l'histoire sur la
simulation de sa propre disparition
alors elle n'était pas du côté de
l'enquêteur mais du côté de celle qui
déclenche la tête lorsqu'elle a disparu
on n'a jamais su ce qu'elle est elle
était devenue en fait on a su elle l
avait réservé une chambre d'hôtel sous
le nom de la maîtresse de son mari hé
oui un signal en fait oui c'est bon on
le sait c'est à la fois un signal à son
mari un publiciste maintenant
magistral merci tous les trois d'avoir
participé à cette émission de l'autre
côté de la frontière de berthet
fromental c'est chez dargaud la
dictatrice de diane ducret c'est chez
flammarion et le dictionnaire amoureux
du général denis ti lignac
c'est chez plon merci de nous avoir
suivis rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]